- [Narrator] Queens, New York
is the most ethnically diverse
urban area in the world.
With over 150 countries represented
and 138 different languages spoken,
a subway fare can transport you
almost anywhere in the world.
And that means that there
is a lot of great food to be eaten here.
A lot.
Flushing, Queens, is one
of the largest Chinatowns
in the world.
And here you can find a dish
that stands out due to
something special: it's color.
Over in Jackson Heights we
head south of the border
and find a flavorful seafood
dish in a very unlikely place.
In Corona there's a stand embracing
the flavors of the South Pacific
and bringing back an old
street food tradition.
In a different part of
Corona, near the 7 train,
is a small shop serving
up extremely large tortas.
Finally, back in Jackson Heights,
in an area called Little Nepal,
we feast on a traditional dish
bursting with flavor and history.